ma question est pour monsieur le premier
ministre
souvenez vous le 14 novembre je
commençais ma question par la discussion
de colbert à mazarin sur le défaut bien
français de toujours taxer imposé
contraindre fiscalement à la fin je vous
prévenait de ne pas faire la même erreur
que marie antoinette en n'entendant pas
la colère monte je ne pensais pas si
bien dire au vu des émeutes qui ont
suivi
n'oublions pas que les premières
revendications de ces manifestations
était arrêté de nous taxer
laissez nous vivre de notre travail par
une pirouette intelligente vous avez mis
en place votre grand débat bel écran de
fumée qui par sa durée les interventions
dithyrambique du président ont fait
oublier le corps du sujet qu'elle n'a
pas été mon étonnement en lisant les
propositions du parti majoritaire et de
vos ministres avec toujours plus de
taxes et d'impôts augmentation des
droits de succession taxation des plus
values sur les résidences principales
retour de la taxe carbone alors monsieur
le premier ministre
quand allez vous enfin comprendre qu'il
faut sortir de cette addiction à l'impôt
pouvez vous vous engagez aujourd'hui à
ne crée ni augmenter aucun impôt merci
monsieur diplôme la parole et à monsieur
gérald darmanin ministre de l'action et
des comptes publics
monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur nous partageons
point de vue qu'avec impôts il faut
utiliser un verbe les baisser monsieur
le sénateur nous sommes tout à fait
favorables à votre proposition c'est
d'autant plus vrai que vous aurez
constaté ce matin que pour la première
fois depuis bien longtemps
l'insee ici même plusieurs fois les
sénateurs et sénatrices à forte raison
ont mis le gouvernement devant des
contradictions avec les chiffres cas
divulguer l'insee que nous n'avons
jamais contesté l'insee a dit d'une part
que nous sommes le gouvernement qui
avons le plus baissé les impôts depuis
désormais 15 ans dans les deux premières
années notre mandat
nous sommes le gouvernement qui avons
baissé en volume ce qui n'a pas existé
depuis plus de 20 ans la dépense
publique
nous sommes le gouvernement qui avons
pour la troisième fois de suite puis un
déficit en dessous de 3% je rappellerai
que lorsque nous sommes arrivés en
responsabilité le déficit est de 3 4% il
baisse désormais de 1 points pour être à
2,5 pour cent et malgré tous les
prophètes de malheur nous avons la
croissance la plus élevée de l'union
européenne et nous avons terminé l'année
2018 avec une croissance 1,6 pour cent
il est vrai monsieur le sénateur il est
vrai monsieur le sénateur que pour
baisser les impôts il faut baisser la
dépense et de ce point de vue et de ce
point de vue il ya beaucoup de croyants
mais peu de pratiquants puisque lorsque
nous proposons de baisser la dépense et
singulièrement à la majorité sénatoriale
dans le détail nous avons quelques
quiproquos
je n'ai pas attendu monsieur le sénateur
de la part du chef de votre partie des
propositions claires de baisse de la
dépense publique bien au contraire
alors oui notre pays doit baisser encore
plus ses impôts c'est ce que nous
faisons sur l'impôt sur les sociétés sur
la taxe sur l'habitation évidemment sur
tout impôt qui demain pourrait rêver
notre économie le premier travail sur
les impôts de production et nous vous
demandons s'il vous plaît de faire une
revue de détail
dites-nous si c'est possible là où vous
souhaitez vous baisser la dépense
publique je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur du plan pour la réplique vous
avez 30 secondes laissées du plan
l'exemple que vient de donner monsieur
darmana monsieur le premier ministre est
exactement le vrai exemple
l'exemple que l'on ne peut pas se
féliciter malgré ce qu'il dit des
résultats avec 76 milliards de déficit
en 2018 alors que l'allemagne compte à
belgique comptabilise 50 9 milliards
avec une dette de 2300 milliards alors
que l'allemagne passe en dessous des 60
% avec 65 milliards déficit sur la
balance commerciale alors que
l'allemagne fait 228 milliards
d'excédents le général de gaulle disait
quand je me regarde je me désole mais
quand je me compare je me console
si la première partie de sa phrase
relate bien la situation de la france
la deuxième partie absolument pas alors
monsieur le premier ministre si vous
voulez enfin vous consoler agissez
agissez vite fait des économies et
arrêter de penser qu'à puiser dans la
bourse des français mais